bonsoir tiens je suis en train de suivre
le truc j'arrive pas c'est parfait
technologie extraordinaire comment on
fait pour tous les gens qui nous
regardent comment on fait pour bien
lancer notre émission on a bien lancé
notre émission c'est comme ça qu'on
démarre normalement ça dépend des
spectacles mais on fait pas tous les
trois coups c'est quand même un truc qui
date maintenant ouais je crois c'est
réservé à la Comédie Française là les
producteurs ont fait les trois coups ou
pas ils producteur on fait pas les trois
coups non on fait on fait plutôt un
petit peu de live avec un
orchestre un orchestre en live ils sont
7 musiciens en train de jouer là et
après et puis après ben c'est parti quoi
ça c'est un bon début peut-être
d'émission ouais parce que moi je vous
ai dit ça ferait un bon plan pour
commencer l'émission on démarre
là-dessus après on recule et on découvre
le foyer du théâtre de bon alors on
essaye
Alexis veut que tu te rapproches
commencer là dessus après comme ça et
puis ensuite on va tranquillement
reculer et découvrir ce magnifique foyer
donc là on recommence attention donc 1 2
3 allez c'est parti voilà c'est pas mal
ça bonsoir Comment ça va bon démolir
c'est une fierté ça les fierté de les
Molière c'est une fierté oui bah oui
c'est super ouais et puis là c'était le
premier
Molière du spectacle musical pour moi en
tout cas pour nous et Benoît codaine
celui qui a eu la révélation masculine
il est actuellement sur scène on
l'entend chanter à celui qui chante là
c'est Serge Postigo et en duo avec lui
et là c'est lui là et Benoit il était il
était dans Edmond
il a il était il jouait un défait d'eau
puisqu'ils ont été plusieurs à jouer
Feydeau
7 ans ça fait depuis 2016 donc ça fait 6
ans c'est la 7e saison et il a il a joué
plus de 700 fois son rôle et puis au
bout de quelques temps je lui dis genre
tu veux pas venir passer l'audition pour
les producteurs et en fait à ce
moment-là il était déjà pris sur le Roi
Lion d'accord ah oui
et producteurs qui sont les mêmes que
les producteurs que les producteurs les
vrais producteurs
évite de le prendre parce qu'il va faire
Pumba dans le Roi Lion
je sais pas s'il va faire Pumba parce
que il est vraiment vraiment très très
bien en leoblum et résultat au final il
s'est retrouvé un joli au Blue mais à
gagner un mois on va le voir là
maintenant oui c'est la fin non alors là
on est en train on n'est pas encore tout
à fait sur la fin alors est-ce qu'on
peut voir la scène des avoir ce qui se
passe je regarde un peu quelle heure il
est parce que on est très timé hein
le problème c'est qu'il y a cette caméra
qui fait beaucoup de personnes
[Musique]
qui vont nous enfermer dans vos cadeaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui va mais vous vous reprenez cette
depuis le début les gars allez
[Musique]
sortir de la prison on essaie de pas de
pas gâcher la fête des spectateurs
maintenant et alors est-ce qu'on peut
aller voir j'ai vu qu'on pouvait passer
pas loin de la scène et le voir sur le
côté non on va gêner les comédiens ou
pas
[Musique]
alors là toujours les comédiens la même
troupe à chaque fois les producteurs oui
mais alors le seul truc c'est que
parfois dans la comédie musicale il faut
être vous faire attention à savoir il
faut faire attention à son corps et
c'est vraiment qui se blesse parfois où
il perdent leur voix et à ce moment-là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait c'est plus physique
il y a des swings qui vont les remplacer
et qui vont remplacer chaque rôle à tour
de rôle et là je crois qu'il y en a un
qui s'est fait un peu mal au dos et qui
est donc dans la salle en train de voir
le spectacle ce soir il a juste derrière
on a la batterie
[Musique]
ce qu'on fait on a mis les musiciens
dans les loges dans les baignoires
alors pareil on va beaucoup couper la
lumière c'est là
[Musique]
comme nous qui est en tranche
soyez un changement
ça va
[Applaudissements]
venir
parce qu'il y a un changement rapide on
peut se retourner
voilà là on est dans les coulisses
[Musique]
bonjour enchanté Thibault
le son là tu peux voir ici les retours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est terminé ça y est c'est fini ah
vous allez monter sur scène là moi non
pas du tout non
par contre on va aller voir saluer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on voit le
soleil
[Musique]
allez on file allez on file
parce qu'il faut qu'on l'explique
on va donc au Théâtre du Palais Royal
maintenant là on va essayer d'arriver à
temps au Théâtre du Palais-Royal pour
choper les saluts du thé du panier Royal
les fleurs
22h10 normalement un taxi nous attend on
va voir on va voir s'il est là
c'est peut-être une autre mais en tout
cas il est parti bon les producteurs
comédie musicale on peut en parler un
petit peu quand même si on en a pas
parlé
on va on va en discuter là on vient de
quitter d'ailleurs Régis Vallet qu'on va
peut-être retrouver tout à l'heure alors
votre ami de toujours voilà mon ami de
20 ans au revoir bonne soirée
ça c'est pour nous ça je pense que c'est
pour nous parfait bonsoir bonsoir ça va
ouais super
bonsoir vous allez bien monsieur c'est
pour aller au stade du palais royal
c'est ça parfait merci beaucoup
on va reculer le fauteuil au maximum
pour notre caméraman comment on peut
faire monsieur
merci beaucoup
alors c'est évidemment le principe des
années directs
on y va
Sylvain tu peux y aller
j'ai pas filmé là non pas du tout
monsieur on va essayer de on va essayer
de pas trop vous avoir dans le champ
merci beaucoup monsieur
bonjour bonjour tu vas allumer ton truc
ou ça va
l'allumer
et donc non les producteurs c'est moi
j'adore la comédie musicale vraiment
depuis toujours je suis un grand fan de
comédie musicale et j'ai et je me suis
toujours dit bon un jour peut-être si
jamais j'ai la chance de monter un show
de Broadway ce serait merveilleux et
puis il faut expliquer c'est un film à
la base de 67 67 qui a été qui a été
réalisé par melbrooke qui avait connu un
énorme succès qui a obtenu l'Oscar du
meilleur scénario et dont il a fait
lui-même une adaptation en comédie
musicale
un merci Monsieur est-ce que ça sonne
aussi pour nous ou pas non ça va
et il en a fait lui-même la propriété
adaptation comédie musicale en 2000 il
me semble à Broadway
énorme succès carton 11 Tony Howards qui
est l'équivalent des Molières mais
là-bas et le show c'est monté un peu
partout sauf en France OK et puis donc
2000 donc on est en 2000 et en 2005 je
crois que c'est en 2004 ou 2005 il y a
le ils font l'adaptation du en film de
la comédie musicale et moi c'est ça que
je découvre moi je découvre ce film
musicale adaptée du film mais un film
adapté de la comédie musicale qui a été
réalisé par la mitose en scène de la
comédie musicale Suzanne strowman et moi
je vois ce film et je me dis bon le film
a des défauts parce que il est très
théâtral justement mais je me dis mais
ça devait être un show incroyable vous
l'avez jamais vu le choix Broadway
avec les mêmes interprètes etc et je me
dis mais il faudrait il faudrait en
faire faudrait faudrait le monter en
France quoi et en attendant comme
évidemment j'avais très jeune et j'avais
pas du tout les moyens de monter un show
comme ça j'ai monté
je vais avoir 40 ans dans trois mois
bravo et donc en 2005 j'avais ouais 20
22 23 un truc comme ça c'est ça et donc
je je décide de monter une comédie
musicale un peu barrée sur ces prix-là
de chaque pierre qui s'appelle La Mégère
à peu près apprivoiser et qui s'est joué
ensuite au splendide notamment et
puis il y avait déjà cet esprit un peu
mieux de melbrooke complètement délirant
des gags voilà dans tous les sens et
puis bon voilà plusieurs années plus
tard je me suis content pas de comédie
musicale non il s'est passé plein de
choses
etc mais donc Flash Forward après avoir
fait de Monts je me retrouve à discuter
avec les producteurs de stage
Entertainment qui ont le Mogador
d'accord Laurent BENTATA Eric Cousteau
et ils me disent mais toi il y a pas un
truc que pas envie de faire en comédie
musicale
si mon rêve c'est les producteurs ils
disent bah tu sais nous ça fait 15 ans
qu'on essaie de le monter d'accord et en
fait coup de chance énorme mais il se
trouve que les droits sont passés de
personnes en personne et que plusieurs
personnes ont essayé de monter le
spectacle mais à chaque fois ouais en
France mais avec un postulat qui était
compliqué il était il y a deux rôles
principaux qui sont les deux producteurs
qui ont été Nelson Lay les matchs des
grandes stars à Broadway il faut des
stars en France
c'est pas que c'est pas mon genre c'est
que moi
mais mais surtout au niveau du théâtre
en tout cas ça c'est sûr et vous le
ferez jamais
on verra mais ça vous excite pas trop
quoi non c'est pas ça mais c'est un
autre débat mais mais en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que là en l'occurrence le
fait de c'est difficile de trouver des
stars françaises qui savent chanter
danser qui vont jouer cette fois par
semaine et qui vont amortir le chaud en
jouant pendant des heures donc c'est
vrai que il y a pas un nom tout de suite
qui vient à l'esprit on n'est pas
vraiment habitué à cette école
américaine ou tout le monde sait que ça
prend du temps il faut se dire que
pendant deux ans une veuette française
vient tous les soirs sur scène ou pas
trop l'esprit quoi non déjà au théâtre
s'il fait l'année c'est super si la
tournée c'est étonnant s'il fait la
tournée donc du coup voilà il y a un
truc de où c'était un calcul difficile
d'arriver à trouver une une paire de
stars capables de faire il y en a
plusieurs qui ont été attachés au projet
mais bon ça c'est jamais fait pour mon
plus gros poney
il y a eu je sais plus ils ont parlé
plusieurs personnes à un moment mais bon
bref
quel est le rapport de force qui a le
pouvoir les producteurs c'est de le dire
ou vous bah là
quand même on se trouve on se trouve et
puis on se dit bon bah comment est-ce
qu'on le fait si on le fait les
producteurs bah déjà il faut les droits
et puis et puis les droits ce sont
libérés un an plus tard donc ils m'ont
rappelé en faisant tiens est-ce qu'on
ferait pas est-ce qu'on le tenterait pas
et puis ensuite il y avait il fallait le
théâtre donc le théâtre de Paris très
vite a été associé au projet et puis il
y avait ce concept de faire une troupe
c'est-à-dire de trouver vraiment des
acteurs talentueux qui savent chanter
qui savent danser des acteurs de têtes
musicales et on en a en France beaucoup
mais mais pas de stars donc faire
vraiment une troupe autour du spectacle
et puis une fois que ce principe a été
accepté
moi j'avais un autre truc que je voulais
c'était vraiment pour voir faire
quelques couples
parce que j'ai écouté quelques
interviews ça ça a été difficile vous
avez appelé le principal concernant ça a
été difficile jusqu'à ce que je finisse
par avoir melbrooke déjà les droits
c'est compliqué mais alors on vous dit
vous touchez pas les Américains sont ils
sont très forts et très procéduriers
aussi donc il y a toujours un avocat et
l'avocat même un avocat etc donc ça
passe par plusieurs canaux avant
d'arriver au principal intéressé donc
souvent chaque canal va dire NON NON
et donc quand on essayait de faire des
demandes un peu dans ce sens là moi je
voulais notamment couper une chanson
parce que je trouvais que elle
ralentissait un peu l'acte 2 et que
j'avais envie que le spectacle soit un
spectacle de 2h sans entracte ok
le débit de boisson tout ça c'est la
culture américaine ça dure 2h30 etc moi
je voulais un show de 2h donc je voulais
couper dedans et finalement j'ai fini
par avoir melbrooks au téléphone un peu
impressionné ou pas bien sûr évidemment
et puis surtout je me disais ou pas
des spectacles quoi mais mais surtout
voilà les gens vivantes il a 95 ans il
se fait tellement de films géniaux culte
il a touché à tout il a eu il a il a
touché à la télévision il a fait des
séries il a fait des films qui ont été
multirés compensées il a fait donc cette
musical qui raflé tous les tonifs
vraiment il a il a vraiment beaucoup
fait de choses il a été producteur on
l'ignore mais il a produit des films où
on trouverait ça improbable que ce soit
melbruck ce producteur et pourtant c'est
bien aussi et les fentman de David
lynchon Man et oui absolument donc voilà
ce genre de carrière folle quoi dans
dans le cinéma dans la télé et
donc j'ai au téléphone et moi j'avais
moi ma mère est anglaise
donc le premier truc ça la rassuré
d'entendre que je parlais anglais et
puis il a un rapport à la France très
fort parce que il a il est venu se
battre en France pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale d'accord c'est à dire
enfin se battre il est il est arrivé à
la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
lui il était un peu dans le déminage
d'accord raconte ça dans son
autobiographie où il était tout jeune et
puis il est il a grandi à New York et
donc il est venu en France et il est il
est allé déminé il en a gardé un lien
très fort avec la France et c'est
pendant cette période d'ailleurs qu'il a
eu
l'inspiration principale de ces
personnages des producteurs frustré lui
que ça se fasse pas en France que ça ne
se soit jamais fait en France il avait
il avait envie que ça se fasse mais mais
comment et quand c'était la question
donc j'ai eu au téléphone et puis passer
cette cette crainte que je parle pas
anglais finalement quand il a vu que ça
allait qu'on pouvait avoir une
conversation il a été rassuré on a
commencé à parler plein de choses
évidemment je lui ai dit à quel point
j'adorais
tout ce qu'il avait fait et que j'avais
pas du tout envie de trahir son son
œuvre mais que j'avais besoin de ces
couples pour le public français et il a
tout de suite fait bon vas-y fais ce que
tu veux et faire d'autres couples
et donc je me suis dit c'est c'est
génial et je la on a
et puis j'étais tout content
il me dit je me rends compte qu'on a
parlé plutôt mais en fait j'ai
merci beaucoup
on passe la soirée avec Alexis Michelin
il faut que je tourne
toujours
on est bien ou pas et pas mal
le récupère ici donc on passe la soirée
ensemble on est avec Alexis Michalik
à 22h tête de Paris allez on va on
arrive ici sur notre plus grand succès
tout à fait donc là on est au Théâtre du
Palais-Royal encore une fois on a les
petits Molières qui sont là
donc ça c'est 2017 et là on va rentrer
dans le cadre du palais royal ça va
bonjour et on va monter et on va aller
découvrir l'autre public ça c'est
l'entrée du public effectivement je suis
en train de checker à chaque fois parce
que
ce qui se passe ou pas souvent non enfin
là le spectacle c'est la
1200e mais là vous voyez on entend des
gens qui nous disent et à votre avis qui
sait
qui sont là et qui nous disent attention
il y a des gens qui parlent bonjour
bonsoir
qui me dit chute
tu vas bien bonjour madame
jouer mais on va venir on va les
découvrir le foyer du palais royal en
direct sur le Figaro live
merci de nous accueillir
c'est beau ça c'est foyer est-ce que
j'ai demandé si tu peux tu peux tu peux
tu peux nous allumer le foyer ou c'est
compliqué
merci c'est gentil
pas du tout de même théâtre le théâtre
de Paris de salle de ambiance
ça c'est un des plus vieux théâtres de
Paris le théâtre du Palais Royal donc ce
foyer il est un petit peu historique là
vous voyez plein d'affiches d'époque
Sacha guittré et en haut il y a une
fresque des comédiens du 19e
qui a été restauré qui est toujours là
aujourd'hui
et là qu'est-ce qu'on entend on attend
la fin parce que c'est les saluts
[Applaudissements]
c'est parfait on va pouvoir se poser 2
secondes
je suis venu la semaine dernière là
c'est la Cyrano qui vient de finir là
donc la pièce de Cyrano vient de finir
donc il reste encore 5 minutes avant d'y
retourner pour la fin bonjour Qui
êtes-vous
ah salut Virginie
la semaine dernière se cache derrière on
m'a parlé de la cage aux folle vous avez
battre le record de la cage aux folles
c'est la vraie question qu'on se pose
tous mais en tout cas on n'osait pas y
arriver et là on commence à rentrer un
peu dans le c'est pas tout à fait la
dernière ligne droite c'est on va dire
que c'est l'avant dernier tour quoi
parce que bon ça se joue tous les tous
les soirs et non se joue tous les soirs
sauf le lundi et je crois maintenant
sauf le mercredi aussi mais depuis
septembre 2016 et on a et là il nous
reste
on va dire on est à 1000 à peu près à
1300 représentations et je sais plus si
la cage aux folles c'est 1006 ou 1007 ou
un truc comme ça donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'on fasse un nom de plus c'est
possible pour arriver à les à les
rattraper c'est possible est-ce que ça
va
c'est pas plein plein c'est pas plein
comme comme de première année on va dire
mais c'est mais oui ça reste ça reste
des très belles salles mais que vous
allez voir tout à l'heure et c'est et
c'est fou quoi c'est fou c'est des c'est
des enfin c'est une aventure dingue tout
ce qui sont dans Edmond vraiment ils ont
vécu il y en a qui sont là depuis le
début il y en a ouais il y a encore des
acteurs qui sont là depuis le début je
parle pas trop fort parce que non parce
que là c'est la fin
vous avez voir la dernière scène ou pas
on peut aller sur le côté on peut mais
il faut éteindre le pièce
on va faire le tour
voilà donc là je vais attendre juste
vous êtes capable de le faire
je connais un petit peu le texte
et surtout j'ai pas envie de déranger le
public et les acteurs
et les autres
je vais attendre le dernier le dernier
monologue
puis après on va y aller
on rit beaucoup sur cette pièce
je suis venu à trois semaines les gens
sont morts
se passe bien j'espère que ça j'espère
que ça diffuse vous avez des retours
vous vous suivez un peu ou pas
vous arrivez à voir s'il y a des gens
qui regardent
non toujours pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non c'est bon c'est bon
donc là ils vont ils vont démonter tout
de suite
ils vont remonter le mur là il y a Serge
le directeur technique quel jour Serge
bonjour
et là on va voir ce qui se passe après
le spectacle
donc là on découvre toute la troupe
bonjour
ça va les gars
bonjour merci de nous accueillir c'est
cool
comment ça va super super naturel avec
une caméra
salut ça fait longtemps qu'on s'est pas
vu
on s'est vu au pot il y a pas très
longtemps quand même
voilà
c'est la fameuse trappe qu'on va
remonter et puis là ils vont remonter le
mur alors attention enfin faire gaffe
parce que il va venir par ici
de le remonter après chaque
représentation
en fait c'est le fait que il y a tout le
temps moi j'ai quand j'écris je me dis
pas alors il y en a il y en a qui sont
là depuis pas très longtemps Arthur là
il fait partie des nouveaux et puis il y
en a qui sont là depuis le début il y a
pierre Bénédicte on a vu tout à l'heure
qui était de la première représentation
qui est là depuis de temps en temps
Augustin lui il est arrivé je crois au
bout de la deuxième année je crois non
2017 donc voilà première année donc il
fait partie de la team 2 voilà et puis
chacun fait de se croise au fur et à
mesure mais voilà en tout cas
et Serge les auditeurs ils en ont fait
un péké
la lumière
je suis allé faire d'autres trucs
bon bah je fais ma dernière allez on
fait la fête j'ai fait quatre spectacles
depuis le début des noms qui n'ont pas
survécu à Edmond avec tout le respect
que j'ai pour cette spectacle j'ai fait
moi-même mais
je reviens toujours avec
plaisir non j'en ai pas marre c'est
toujours
je joue toute une galerie de personnes
qui fait Marcel hein
montre-nous
le respect qui allait faire pour la
course l'amour que j'ai trouvé relation
particulière que tu es sur J'aime
on est on a eu il a non il a failli se
faire mais bon comme appétissants on a
eu un accueil un accueil unique en Corse
vraiment un accueil unique vous avez
fait les tournées vous avez fait ici ici
c'est depuis 2016 puis septembre 2016
et là si vous venez on va vous montrer
les coulisses les coulisses du du
spectacle c'est Sylvain nous rejoindre
les coulisses on voit le un peu la
mécanique
personne en fait tu vas bien
donc là voilà on est en train de
récupérer les tous les tous les costumes
on est encore sur scène parce qu'il y a
des il y a une loge au changement rapide
et là il y a tous les costumes de tout
le monde alors là c'est réglé comme du
papier à musique comme du papier à
musique il y a Nathalie qui est en train
de travailler et qui a récupéré les
trucs à nettoyer
combien de costumes sans costume
oui parce que comme c'est pas toujours
la même équipe
ah oui ça fait du
merci beaucoup
qui est le chien de Serge et qui est sur
scène tous les soirs qui a fait toutes
les représentations depuis le début
depuis le début absolument qui est le
chemin le chien le plus doux du monde et
ici beau flacon flacon
en fait donc les comédiens quand ils
sont en coulisse ils peuvent voir sur ce
grand écran ce qui se passe sur ça le
moment où ils doivent revenir alors il
sort rarement encore il sort rarement
mais quand même il y en a qui ont des
fois un petit peu le temps et là vous
allez voir je sais pas si je vais si
c'est assez de lumière alors peut-être
rallumer la petite loupiote là on va
voir
donc je vais donc 6 octobre
1283e représentation on se cache un peu
la recette et voilà donc on a tous les
soirs affiché
1283e
374 entrée ça c'est ce soir et là il y a
une petite photo avec Jean-Michel
martial qui a créé le rôle d'Honoré et
qui nous a quitté il y a il y a déjà
quelques années maintenant qui a eu le
temps de faire le rôle dans le film et
puis ensuite et puis ensuite
malheureusement il est parti donc il est
toujours il est toujours avec nous sur
scène quoi parce que là c'est la petite
régie des régisseurs et puis quand on
descend
et cuisine tranquille et puis quand on
descend là on va descendre vers les
loges
donc là voilà moi je vais juste boire un
petit coup de boule
j'espère qu'on capte parce que c'est pas
gagné
au niveau des Loges on a ici les
[Musique]
acteurs
Bénin
alors là on va arriver dehors je sais
pas si on va recapter ce qu'on capte à
nouveau c'est la question c'est bon on
regarde désolé pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent on a une petite coupure c'est
un peu le prix de notre direct ça ne
s'arrête jamais c'est le direct
et qu'on branche alors qu'on a souvent
les journalistes par exemple dans des
magnifiques et donc pour partir sur le
terrain d'accord on mange ça avec la
caméra ok bien ceux qui lui carte SIM
dedans et ça renvoie aussi
et ça nous permet donc de diffuser en
direct on va voir votre public ou pas
on est sur la fin
je vais vous montrer on va juste passer
dehors le temps qu'ils arrivent
hop là
on peut voir un magnifique balcon
extérieur
donc on pourrait sortir du théâtre vous
êtes en direct sur le Figaro life
vous sortez de la montre ça vous a plu
vous pouvez vous pouvez venir nous en
parler ou pas bah venez alors
viens Sylvain viens bonjour comment vous
appelez
Sylvain comment ça s'est passé
moderne à la pauvre
vous savez qui c'est
[Musique]
ma pièce que vous voulez voir en fait
c'est le pâtissier je suis désolé
on va aller jusqu'à minuit et on se
balade de théâtre en théâtre en fait
tout simplement
moi je suis Alexis je suis le docteur et
metteur en scène voilà c'est ça parce
que je suis une grande fan de Cyril
Bergerac j'ai vu
[Musique]
la pièce de mon instant j'ai vu le film
plein de fois avec Depardieu
j'ai pleuré
c'est comme Billy Elliot 14 fois et donc
j'avais trois devoirs Edmond et c'est et
vous faites quoi dans la vie vous mais
moi je là je montre gentiment dans la
vie active d'accord donc c'est pas du
tout dans le théâtre non pas du tout
super
du théâtre et une lettre et donc si ça
nous est un peu incontournable
vous êtes en direct sur le Figaro live
non pas souvent non non seulement quand
il y a des nouveaux et puis là comme
quand il y a une émission plutôt à venir
être devant une caméra et aller dire
bonjour mais non mais on a fêté on a
fait on a fêté la reprise samedi de
conserve tous vu samedi soir voilà bon
merci c'est trop gentil
ou pas
c'est un classique Cyrano revisité mais
voilà mais c'est vrai qu'on est dans un
théâtre à l'ancienne etc si on a
alexandrin c'est il y a des Verts et
tout bon comme c'est classique
[Rires]
qui a été qui a été construit et là on
va aller on va aller parler aux comédien
on va aller parler à Pierre bénessey
encore une fois la star comment
Tiphaine bonjour Tiphaine enchanté
[Rires]
[Musique]
on va aller parler à d'autres comédiens
parce que Pierre Bénédicte c'est bien
gentil mais bon allez voir on l'a déjà
beaucoup
bonsoir bonsoir ça vous a plu trop cool
[Rires]
merci à vous
abonner
je suis là vous êtes très très bon
qu'est-ce qui passe
[Musique]
Sonia qui joue Jeanne
Benjamin qui joue Edmond juste derrière
le spectacle
[Musique]
regardez elle a déjà sa valise donc là
demain soir
parce qu'on est des fois trois ou quatre
acteurs sur chaque rôle ce qui permet
effectivement de jouer en tournée et à
Paris en béton
[Musique]
droit différents
de deux ans donc là c'est une dernière
date restante a priori la dernière
tournée ça se passe
[Rires]
et je suis revenu puisque je suis en
train de faire plaisir à être là donc
j'ai joué
possible de rater encore le texte encore
non mais après c'est assez drôle mais
c'est bien aussi en même temps ça veut
dire dans un état un peu d'éventuel
fragilité ce qui permet que on est dans
le présent encore même après avoir joué
vous avez pas l'impression d'arriver au
bureau et de sortir
les acteurs
avec l'alternance on est toujours un peu
surpris par les autres personnes qui euh
qui viennent jouer moi la première fois
toujours différemment j'adore cette idée
que tu m'as forts
bah ouais ouais mais en tout cas si
c'est dans cette situation là la
disposition
on est en live donc tout ça va être euh
vous avez pas de problème on te détester
pendant ce temps Sandra Dorset n'aime
pas champignons c'est le secours c'est
le scoop alors nous on en est où est-ce
qu'on va est-ce qu'on est dans dans
laquelle on est dans le temps alors on a
un taxi dans une dizaine de minutes 10
minutes
on peut retourner dans le palais royal
faire un petit tour on trouve
pas dans dans le théâtre non dans le
hall je suis même pas sûr j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont fermé sinon
alors
je voudrais aller un petit tour je sais
pas si le passage ici est ouvert
on va faire le tour alors
allez ciao les gars bonne journée
salut
bon courage bye bye je peux vous poser
la question qui flashent
ça rapporte combien d'avoir fait une
pièce comme ça est-ce que vous le savez
déjà bah oui quand même je suis quand
même intéressé
difficile mais c'est très simple parce
que c'est depuis Beaumarchais il existe
ce qu'on appelle des droits d'auteur
donc les droits d'auteur le concept est
on peut on ne peut plus simple c'est un
pourcentage de la recette en fait donc
concrètement si la pièce marche pas il y
en aura pas grand chose et si la pièce
marche on aura un pourcentage fixe donc
en fait à la différence des stars de
cinéma c'est pas des cachets qu'on
discute ou qu'on négocie c'est en gros
l'auteur il touche 10% de la recette
donc au début quand vous vendez la pièce
vous ne touchez rien quand la pièce se
monte c'est jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
montée l'auteur il touche rien quoi
et après une fois que la pièce se joue à
l'auteur touche un pourcentage de des
droits donc si ça marche pas et que ça
s'arrête au bout de 30 représentation
bah il aura pas touché grand-chose
bon si ça marche par contre là c'est là
c'est super donc là
est-ce que après Edmond votre vie change
ou pas ou ça a tourné déjà vous allez
déjà vos pièces déjà à partir du porteur
d'histoire la vie a pas mal changé parce
que avant Edmond il y a eu porteur
d'histoire et le porteur d'histoire
c'est une pièce qui se joue maintenant
attention je fais
qui se joue depuis on va parler
qui se joue depuis un bon bout de temps
quoi depuis un bon bout de temps puisque
puisque ça a commencé en 2011 et et
voilà et ça joue depuis sans s'arrêter
quoi donc c'est assez c'est assez
extraordinaire donc ça c'est le premier
ça c'est le ça c'est le premier premier
vrai gros succès ouais surtout en fait
c'est la première fois que j'ai écrit un
code pièce avant ça je faisais des
classiques revisités la mégère à peu
près les voisins Roméo et Juliette tout
ça et le mariage
c'est vrai que le mariage c'est mon
premier spectacle et d'ailleurs je je ne
mens pas de le citer à chaque fois que
je passe au client et avec son avec son
esprit frondeur et sans la liberté de
blâmer et des points des Loges
exactement et d'ailleurs j'en profite un
petit peu de promo vous pouvez trouver
le journal demain matin au kiosque avec
bon marché et cette phrase
tous les jours et ce monologue
d'ailleurs il est génial c'est l'un des
monologues d'ailleurs que je connais par
cœur donc
voilà donc il y avait des reprises de
spectacle et puis un jour ben le porteur
d'histoire un peu par accident je me
suis retrouvé à écrire ce spectacle et
enfin créer et à partir de là ma vie
artistique en tout cas je suis un sacré
virage puisque comme le spectacle a
marché au-delà de tout ce que tous donc
je pouvais rêver j'ai commencé à j'ai
commencé j'essaie de me faire en sorte
de ne pas être en commande avec vous
parce que j'ai quand même un peu la
notion de la caméra et non et du coup à
partir de là oui effectivement ma vie a
changé un peu je me suis dit bon bah
puisque puisque ça peut intéresser
quelqu'un de de
ce que j'écris je vais continuer à
écrire et je vais essayer d'écrire un
deuxième spectacle de voir ce que ça
donne
c'était le cercle des illusionnistes qui
se joue aussi encore aujourd'hui et le
cercle c'était en 2014 et à partir du
cercle en fait on a eu des on a commencé
à avoir des Molières et là bon bah voilà
il y a un autre coup d'accélérateur et
ensuite il y a eu Edmond et là et de
Mons a été un tel triomphe que tout à
coup moi quand j'ai créé le porteur déjà
je trouvais ça dingue d'avoir une pièce
à l'affiche quand j'ai créé le Cercle je
finis non mais je vais avoir deux
spectacles en même temps c'est fou puis
à partir des démons ça a été 3 et puis
intra-muros un quatrième et il sent
vraiment un cinquième et là maintenant
avec les producteurs ça fait 6
spectacles est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en
train de les perdre ce spectacle parce
qu'il nous appartiennent encore c'est
loin maintenant bah oui bien sûr ça fait
loin moi souvent quand je retourne voir
le porteur d'histoire parce que il y a
un acteur ou une actrice qui va
reprendre un rôle je vois ce spectacle
et je me je le vois avec un peu de recul
et après je l'ai tellement vu et
tellement connu traversé
alors vous en pensez du diable ou pas
tant que ça oui bien sûr
non mais
je suis pas un immense fan de Molière
pour ne rien vous cacher c'est pas mon
c'est pas mon préféré moi j'ai quand
même une
admiration sans borne pour Shakespeare
bon on pouvait pas
donc voilà dans la tradition homo
saxonne le récit il est il est très il
est dégueulasse c'est à dire que c'est
pas une histoire entre un père son fils
une maison un intérieur Conforama
c'est très français ouais l'autofiction
le côté l'intériorité le le récit
minimaliste etc c'est très français en
l'école anglo-saxonne c'est Marvel quoi
c'est c'est voilà et Shakespeare déjà
quand il fait des pièces il les place
dans des univers complètement fou et
Beaumarchais d'ailleurs
c'est un peu Shakespeare parce que ces
personnages sont ils les placent en
Espagne pour pas heurter la noblesse et
enfin voilà et la plupart des gens que
j'adore ils ont tous une admiration pour
Shakespeare
et de mon Rostand une admiration pour
Shakespeare Rostand dans sa villa Arnaga
dans le Pays Basque qui s'est fait
construire suite au succès de Cyrano il
a trois bustes
c'est Shakespeare il y a pas Molière
donc voilà il y a le droit d'être
français de ne pas aimer Molière non
mais je vais dire après évidemment que
Molière il y a plein de choses super on
est obligé de dire ça mais moi je le
problème avec la langue de Molière c'est
que et à vrai dire les Anglais ils ont
un peu ce problème là il s'expire c'est
qu'en fait c'est une langue qui est
évidemment datée c'est difficile Molière
faut qu'on peine dessus quoi c'est pas
un truc facile à entendre quoi c'est
c'est ça commence à avoir quelques
siècles et on peut pas y toucher une
virgule alors que Shakespeare bah en
fait on traduit donc on traduit il y a
pas de problème nous on peut l'adapter
aujourd'hui on peut avoir une certaine
modernité donc donc
voilà il y a une il y a une il y a une
différence c'est que nous Molière il est
comme ça et moi je me souviens d'être
collégien et d'aller avec ma classe voir
un Molière et de voir tous mes être
complètement
larguer quoi enfin et même moi de me
dire oh là là c'est difficile quand même
cette phrase surtout quand c'est des
verres avec Sandra voilà ça plus le côté
un peu
pour moi il y a les scénarios sont
tellement plus forts que dans chez
Shakespeare mais voilà c'est des choses
intimes et personnelles et ça se
retrouve prendriez pas
à choisir non c'est pas vraiment le
premier spectacle que j'aimerais que
j'aimerais faire oser lui dire en face
mais non mais je il est évidemment il
représente c'est la langue de Molière
donc c'est l'emblème et puis le l'homme
de troupe voilà je respecte énormément
l'homme de troupes qui étaient Molière
j'adore j'adore le je veux dire c'était
dans un comédien Molière c'était donc un
poème metteur en scène je pense c'était
et voilà et la production qu'il a fait
le la richesse qu'il a donné à ses
spectacles etc mais bon ça reste ça
reste pas exactement ce que je préfère
dans le théâtre
on va retourner
[Musique]
c'est bien mon cheval de bataille on va
dire c'est bien ce que j'essaie de
combattre c'est le fait de trouver le
diadieau quoi
moi je sais que j'ai grandi à Paris et
mes parents avaient le bon goût de
m'emmener au théâtre moi j'ai grandi on
va dire qu'on était au classement
moyenne intellectuel voilà on n'avait
pas beaucoup de sous mais par contre
mes parents les bons goût quoi il
s'était installé à Paris ma mère est
anglaise mon père est du Nord de la
France leur Maubeuge d'origine polonaise
et ils sont tous les deux installés à
Paris et puis voilà on a grandi dans les
années moi j'ai grandi dans les années
80 avec mon frère et il nous emmenait au
cinéma on n'avait pas de télé à la
maison on allait à la bibliothèque
toutes les semaines nous emmener au
cinoche et nous emmener voir les pièces
et
à tout le monde parce que tout le monde
et surtout quand on est pas parisien
c'est vrai c'est difficile et puis même
quand même quand on va au théâtre on va
pas forcément avoir le virus mais moi je
l'ai chopé de manière directe frontale
de deux façons déjà parce que en sixième
je crois je suis arrivé sur scène enfin
je suis arrivé au club théâtre du
collège et voilà ma mère m'avait dit
tiens il y a un club théâtre c'est bon
moi je vais aller voir et j'arrive et il
montait la conversation synchronieta de
Jean Tardieu d'accord voilà qui est une
sorte de caisse courte une sorte d'opéra
mais mais poétique et puis c'était le
deuxième cours de théâtre et ils me
disent bah tous les rôles ont un peu été
donné qu'est-ce que tu peux faire bah
tiens la prof me dit prends un crayon et
va faire le chef d'orchestre donc j'ai
pris le crayon puis je suis allé
improviser le chef d'orchestre et là
j'ai pris le virus quoi et à partir de
là tous les ans ont monté un spectacle
collège lycée Jules Ferry à Paris parce
que Clichy et
voilà et c'était c'était génial et suite
à ça et ben en même temps parallèlement
mes parents m'emmenaient voir des
spectacles au bout du Nord et m'emmener
voir des pièces de Peter Brou qui
m'emmenait voir pièce de Ariane
mouchkine la Cartoucherie m'emmener voir
ils m'ont emmené voir Simon maxborn et à
Bobigny alors vous vous avez cette
chance comment vous faites pour ceux qui
n'ont pas et comment vous essayez de
l'amener à eux dans tous ces spectacles
donc je parle c'est les spectacles
c'est les spectacles qui sont
qui sont du théâtre public et le théâtre
public c'est c'est génial j'ai vu des
trucs merveilleux mais pas récent c'est
pas c'est pas difficile qui joue
longtemps donc quand on voit une super
pièce dans le tête public c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut recommander aux
gens d'y aller
en ce moment avec avec
théâtre privé donc là il y a pas de
question politique presque à ça marche
ça reste ça ne marche pas ça s'en va
exactement et c'est aussi simple que ça
mais c'est difficile que ça marche donc
c'est ça le c'est ça tout le truc et moi
j'ai j'ai commencé j'ai découvert
vraiment le la création théâtrale la
première fois que j'ai créé une pièce
et ça a été mon
ça a été mon épiphanie quoi tout à coup
j'ai découvert ce que c'était que le Off
d'Avignon et je me suis dit bah voilà
c'est ça en fait c'est comme ça que
fonctionne le théâtre c'est ça
l'économie du théâtre j'avais aucune
idée de ce que c'était l'économie du
théâtre et j'ai compris que une jeune
compagnie pouvait grâce au Festival
d'Avignon OFF vendre des dates de
tournée ah bon ah ouais on peut vendre
des dates de tournée et ensuite en
vendant ces dates là ça devient
professionnel voilà et avant vous faites
ça pour le plaisir et d'un seul coup moi
j'étais comédien au départ et j'adorais
jouer et je m'étais dit je vais monter
un spectacle un peu comme ça pour voir
et en fait de fil en aiguille j'ai
compris qu'on pouvait vivre de monter
des spectacles et puis surtout j'ai
commencé à avoir des réactions de gens
beaucoup plus enthousiastes que celle
que j'avais en tant que comédien quoi
donc tiens voilà on arrive au bar
évidemment qui au bar il y avait
toujours le même les acteurs
un vecteurs pierre Bénédicte encore une
fois c'est vrai que
je bois un Périer dans l'année c'est
aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu'on est là
c'est bien c'est bien qu'une fois je
peux t'en prendre un peu évidemment
il va pas tarder non tranquille
tranquille on a pas un taxi en fait il
est pas encore là on a pas de taxi je
répète alerte alerte on va au bélier à
la sortie d'une pièce donc tu as
peut-être entendu parler les couper
personne je l'ai vu j'ai même eu
l'occasion de la voir à Avignon juste un
peu moins même de jouer je me suis
demandé comment j'allais faire pour
jouer ce que je pouvais plus parler
c'est une très bonne amie à moi et Régis
vallée qui a mis en scène la pièce et
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure saluer à la
fin des producteurs lui a mis en scène
et elle elle a écrit la pièce c'est quoi
votre prochaine pièce moi ma prochaine
pièce
est-ce qu'il y a des projets c'est une
question qu'on a sur Youtube
[Rires]
ce sera ce sera demain en replay sur
Youtube vous verrez
non je sais pas ce que ça va être ma
prochaine pièce en fait en général moi
mon problème c'est que dès que je me
mets à dire mon prochain le projet c'est
ça un prochain film c'est ça ma
prochaine pièce c'est ça ça se fait pas
d'une manière ou d'une autre donc j'en
parle et puis je me dis genre non
finalement je vais faire autre chose et
du coup la fois d'après je revois les
journalistes et il me disent alors vous
avez fait votre truc je fais bah non
il y a quelque chose en quelque chose
dans ma tête en tout cas il y a quelque
chose dans ma tête pour l'année
prochaine on va dire donc je ouais je
pense que j'ai une idée de ce que j'ai
envie de faire mais ça se trouve je vais
faire complètement autre chose donc mais
en tout cas oui il y a quelque chose qui
commence à s'écrire à ça les producteurs
alors vous l'avez pas écrit non tout à
fait la dernière pièce écrite c'était
une histoire d'amour à la Scala donc ça
commence à faire un moment là ça
commence à faire un moment là pas tout à
fait non une histoire d'amour c'est de
début 2020 donc ça fait deux ans là mais
mais ouais ça fait un bout de temps ça
fait un bout de temps de 3 ans mais en
même temps c'est pas tant que c'est pas
tant que je suis en panne d'inspiration
c'est que j'ai il y a six spectacles à
l'affiche quoi à un moment mais vous
êtes en train de me dire que vous vous
reposez un peu sur vos lauriers quoi
vous avez pas besoin non des artistes
qui disent ouais mais quand on a perdu
le l'urgence on est moins bon et puis on
a plus rien à dire
oui
il y a moins d'urgence c'est sûr j'ai
pas l'obligation mais sincèrement moi
j'ai pas vraiment non plus ce besoin de
courir après vie toujours plus toujours
plus je suis pas je suis pas là dedans
quoi en fait vraiment je pourrais
m'arrêter aller faire la planche à voile
quoi ça m'irait très bien mais comme
j'ai encore envie de raconter des choses
je vais continuer la raconter mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que la chance est
énorme que j'ai eu c'est que tous ces
spectacles que j'ai monté qui se jouent
actuellement c'est que des spectacles
que j'ai eu envie de faire envie de
raconter et qui sont issus de mon propre
désir il y a pas un moment il y a pas un
de ces spectacles ou c'est un producteur
qui est venu voir en me disant écrit
parce que c'est possible
non ça arrive des commandes ou des ou
des autres
c'est votre idée où on vous dirait ça
peut marcher
c'est moi en fait je voulais faire un je
voulais faire le taxi arrive donc
le taxi arrive dans 4 minutes ok c'est
noté merci
on peut dire que cette personne Virginie
exactement dans l'ombre
et non et donc et donc oui c'est moi je
voulais faire le film avant de faire la
pièce je voulais absolument faire Edmond
au cinéma à la base c'est une idée pour
le ciné j'avais écrit le scénario pour
une boîte de production les jambes et
donc comme premier film comme premier
film et c'était un samedi même pas être
moi qui devait réaliser on l'a proposé à
plusieurs réalisateurs qui ont tous dit
non parce que le théâtre ça les
intéresse pas
de il y a pas on se balance pas et voilà
et et suite à ça deux ans plus tard un
truc comme ça
je me suis dit mais non mais en fait si
je le faisais au théâtre et on allait
voir le théâtre du Palais Royal et on
leur a pitcher le concept et ils ont dit
bon bah ouais super ils ont la pièce ils
sont d'y aller on y va et on l'a créé au
palais royal en septembre 2016 et suite
à ça ça a tellement marché que tout à
coup les gens qui nous invitent disent
non c'est pas une bonne idée on n'a pas
les moyens pour le financer on fait
genre très bonne idée de faire être bon
au cinéma faisons-le et là j'ai dit ok
mais j'aimerais bien le réaliser et hop
le théâtre bon on en a parlé beaucoup le
cinéma infime un petit peu ouais bah non
un deuxième qui arrive en mars alors
c'est quoi c'est une histoire d'amour
une fois de plus vous oui mais alors la
différence
c'est que là en fait j'avais pas du tout
prévu d'en faire un film et c'est
ça et d'ailleurs le film d'Edmond et la
pièce sont c'est quasiment le même texte
donc à vous là c'est différent j'avais
vraiment envie de de j'avais envie d'en
faire une pièce point quoi et puis en
fait il s'est passé que la pièce s'est
retrouvée
dès le début les gens sont venus et mon
dijambon mais en fait ça ressemble à un
film tu veux pas en faire un film tu
peux pas en faire un film et puis à
force ça finit par rentrer dans ma tête
et puis là qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu le
confinement mars 2020 on s'est retrouvé
chez soi je me suis dit bon bah est-ce
que j'essaierai pas d'en faire un
scénario et j'ai commencé à adapter
parce que contrairement Edmond qui était
un film dans ma tête à la base ça
c'était une pièce et donc comme c'était
une pièce je voulais surtout pas qu'il y
a un sentiment de théâtralité dans le
film et de fil en aiguille j'ai fini par
sortir un scénario et trouver on a créé
notre boîte de prod avec mes films et on
a trouvé les fonds pour faire ce film et
la suite ce sera dans le texte dans le
taxi exactement allez bonne soirée les
gars au revoir
bonjour bonjour
on a pas de bagages
merci merci
on peut rappeler peut-être pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent Alexis ce qu'on est en
train de faire il est quelle heure
il nous reste encore 52 minutes
exactement
ça c'est chouette vraiment le côté
vraiment deux heures ensemble de
ambulation c'est c'est assez original
quand même
ah oui c'est vrai
dans le 18e à côté du Joffre merci
beaucoup 18e qui est le donc
l'arrondissement dans lequel j'ai grandi
sur Paris
pur parisien de diverses origines mais
ouais pure parisien je j'ai grandi ouais
vers Pigalle Abbesses
qui est la rue de l'épicier de d'Amélie
Poulain OK et voilà j'étais à l'école
Oudon qui est rue Oudon et qui est la
première ZEP de Paris
et aujourd'hui encore dans le 18e
aujourd'hui je suis à l'école
aujourd'hui j'ai aujourd'hui j'ai
déménagé d'un arrondissement je suis
dans le 19e vous pourriez quitter Paris
le problème c'est le problème le truc
c'est que quand même le théâtre c'est
ici que ça se passe quoi donc c'est
difficile de déménager
dans une autre ville quoi vous parlez du
confinement marqué
à ce moment-là vous faites quoi vous
êtes en face de création ou plutôt
l'inverse ou d'imposer complètement
c'était la décompression c'était la
première fois que tous mes spectacles
étaient à l'arrêt c'était génial
parce qu'il y a quand même un truc non
mais c'est super
ma gueule mais disons que d'avoir une
petite pause de ok là en fait je n'ai
absolument rien qui se joue et donc je
n'irai pas de maintenance à faire même
si aujourd'hui c'est c'est pas moi qui
fait la maintenance j'ai quand même à
chaque fois sur chaque pièce des
assistants etc des gens qui travaillent
et c'est quand même très agréable et
très confortable mais c'est quand même
une charge mentale on va dire d'avoir
des trucs qui jouent et de qu'à tout
moment il peut y avoir un acteur
remplacé un problème ceci et c'est à
dire que vous sortez à ce moment-là du
rôle d'auteur quoi vous êtes aussi
pour que la machine fonctionne
d'entreprise quoi l'un des chefs
d'entreprise de cette de cette belle
entreprise qui ont qui quand on cumule
tous les spectacles embauche
sans entre 100 et 150 acteurs comme ça
quoi est-ce que c'est c'est ta ceinture
Sylvain ça du coup je crois on va
essayer d'attacher la ceinture de
Sylvain
ça c'est un travail ça c'est voilà tu
vois en parler demain dans le cambouis
je crois qu'on est bon merci Monsieur
donc confinement pas de spectacle est-ce
que vous écrivez
j'ai écrit autre chose j'ai écrit un
roman qui s'appelle loin oui tout à fait
ça a été une super expérience
ouais c'est un petit peu ouais
alors ça aussi c'est une histoire je
vous ai un peu écouté à la base là vous
voulez faire une série ouais c'était une
série dans ma tête et puis mais quand
j'étais très jeune en fait c'est né
parce que à l'époque on était en tournée
avec un spectacle qui s'appelait Romeo
et Juliette qui était un Roméo et
Juliette où on était trois dedans il y
avait Régis vallée on va retrouver
normalement tout à l'heure qui on a mis
toujours et mon acteur de toujours et il
y avait un ami LCA une autre de
nouvelles crises de toujours et on est
et moi-même et on tournait tous les
trois dans ce dans ce spectacle et en
fait on était dans notre petite voiture
Régis conduisait moi je faisais une
copilote et Anna était derrière elle
dormait en général et on allait de ville
en ville et on jouait c'était super et
je me suis tiens c'est marrant ce trio
là il y a une dynamique dans le trio et
Anna c'est je la considère un peu comme
ma sœur et donc il y avait il y avait ce
trio un peu des trois qui se baladent et
je me suis dit serait chouette de
d'imaginer une série qui va de pays en
pays avec un trio de jeune quoi et de
Live venu l'idée de loin et puis parce
qu'on peut expliquer ce que alors loin
c'est l'histoire d'un d'un d'un jeune
homme Antoine qui a 26 ans donc là je
connais à peu près quand on tournait au
début et qui a une sœur qui s'appelle
Anna qui à 19 ans qui est d'ailleurs le
nom d'Anna mon actrice et puis et puis
il a un meilleur ami Laurent et ce trio
en fait va partir sur les routes parce
que il va recevoir une carte postale
envoyer par son père tu n'as jamais vu
qu'il n'a jamais vu enfin ici qui est
parti quand il avait 7 ans et son père
en fait a disparu donc on sait pas où il
est parti il reçoit une carte postale
qui a été égarée par la poste et qui a
été envoyé d'un petit village autrichien
il y a 17 ans donc il part sur les
traces de son père et là ça va être le
début du voyage et c'est un roman je
parle du voyage qui parle de la liberté
qui parle de l'envie de voyager qui
parle de de l'identité de d'où on vient
de où on va enfin tout ces choses là
toutes ces questions
aussi dans le temps dans vos spectacle
mais je suis passionné par l'histoire et
par je trouve qu'on a un matériau
inépuisable de récit et d'aventure donc
donc oui donc effectivement loin
traversent un peu une certaine une
certaine histoire de l'Europe au 20e
siècle si vous pouviez faire une journée
dans le passé n'importe quoi n'importe
quand avant vous pas mal de choix une
journée mais là il y a pas le choix une
seule je pense que le XIXe siècle à
Paris ça me brancherait pas mal quoi le
l'espèce de siècle du théâtre en fait la
première de Serrano première de Cyrano
ça peut être pas mal mais même 1850 la
biche fait d’eau tout et j'aimerais bien
cette période ouais Haussmann les grands
travaux voir Paris d'avant vraiment bien
le 19e ça m'intrigue
mais voilà le théâtre le théâtre les
romans les films vous avez le temps de
rien en fait
non mais le roman c'est autre chose
parce que parce que honnêtement je me
suis rendu compte que
l'expérience avoir écrit je suis très
contente d'être allé au bout mais par
contre c'est très solitaire on passe
devant Mogador on parlait de droit
devant
est-ce que s'il va tourner la caméra
réussie à choper le Roi Lion je sais pas
sorti Stage Entertainment
énorme spectacle aussi le roi et non de
production tout à fait
très fort vous me disiez donc le roman
un peu différent c'est différent parce
que c'est solitaire parce que quand on
quand on a fini son roman avec les gens
le lisent en fait on n'a pas de on a pas
ce qu'on a vu là tout à l'heure vous
voyez quand on est avec avec l'équipe
des producteurs ou l'équipe des noms
vous voyez la troupe que c'est des gens
qui partent en voyage qui se croisent
qui repartent qui vont boire des coups
après le spectacle ça c'est ça c'est le
c'est l'esprit de troupe donc vous avez
fait un roman vous êtes primor romancé
vous en ferez pas un deuxième enfin faut
de la manière jamais mais pour l'instant
c'est pas le projet en tout cas c'est
pas le truc le plus urgent je pense que
j'avais envie de à la fois de me prouver
que j'étais capable d'écrire un bouquin
et et surtout de raconter cette histoire
là mais maintenant qu'elle a été
racontée
en général les histoires qui
[Musique]
donc
voilà non mais après je suis un peu j'ai
un peu l'impression quand même d'être le
chef d'une grande famille la célibataire
mais mais entre
entre les six spectacles etc
l'entreprise le machin le boulot les
voyages bon c'est c'est pas forcément un
choix
volontaire mais en attendant la liberté
qui qui va avec cette situation me
permet aussi de faire tout ce que je
fais et aussi de prendre voilà les
vacances si nécessaire quoi et vous
pourriez rencontrer quelqu'un en dehors
du théâtre
non
ouais non mais je pense quand même que
c'est pas mal de d'avoir
déjà d'avoir un peu des trucs à se
raconter le soir quoi plutôt que de
plutôt que de vivre les mêmes les mêmes
choses et puis j'ai été avec des
comédiennes mais c'est pas toujours
facile quand on quand on fait le même
métier il y a toujours un peu de soit de
compète soit de déception déjà aussi
enfin bon bref c'est c'est un métier
c'est un ascenseur émotionnel quand on
est comédien comédienne
on joue on est tout le temps dans les
montagnes russes ah ça je joue c'est
génial et en même temps je suis pas
content parce que ça j'aimerais aussi
faire ça je joue pas c'est terrible
c'est la déprime donc c'est c'est
compliqué quand on est tous les deux du
même métier je respecte infiniment les
couples les couples du métier parce que
évidemment Dieu sait qu'il y en a vous
avez vous aviez
œuvré pendant le confinement pour pour
que le théâtre revienne comment vous
avez agi à l'époque vous avez du poids
vous arrivez à parler par exemple avec
les politiques est-ce que vous jouez
plusieurs pièces dans Paris est-ce que
vous les voyez non pas du tout
vraiment pas du tout non
je pense que non tout ce que je peux
faire c'est essayer de
je sais pas en fait de faire mon taf de
d'inspirer du mieux que je peux de
d'essayer de temps de la main vers des
jeunes
mettant en scène créateur créatrice
acteur actrice d'essayer de faire
tourner un peu
l'effectif et puis déjà ce que voilà je
pense que déjà ce que je fais sur sur le
terrain entre guillemets c'est déjà
politique quoi de faire du tas de santé
d'affiches d'aller chercher
voilà de donner des rôles
très important des comédiens qui voilà
dans d'autres circonstances il y a 15-20
ans aurait eu besoin d'être connu pour
les obtenir c'est déjà assez chouette
après
niveau politique non je suis pas très
privé quoi c'est pas du théâtre public
française aussi vous avez des comptes à
régler avec eux aussi
non pas du tout non j'aime bien ce
qu'ils font
leur spectacle non non j'ai aucun
problème
je pense pas qu'il pourrait m'appeler
parce que c'est pas leur et pourquoi
c'est ça et je comprends pas oui mais
vous êtes on va pas se mentir l'auteur
la personnalité actuelle doit être
français pourquoi vous ne pouviez pas
vous pourriez pas à la Comédie française
parce que je fais je sais pas je fais un
théâtre privé quoi il y a un truc il y a
en fait je pense que entre le monde du
public et du privé il y a un certain
snobisme qui va dans un sens et pas dans
l'autre
dans le cadre privé vraiment on est
hyper heureux d'avoir automatique
plutôt des trucs dans le public venir
faire un truc dans le privé il y a aucun
souci quoi c'est très simple en fait
c'est bien ça marche on est content
c'est aussi simple que ça peut-être
public c'est un thé de recherche c'est
un théâtre de travail c'est un théâtre
sur lequel les
vas-y sont
vus de la part du point de vue
de ce que représente le théâtre
d'intérêt public
il y a vraiment des trucs que j'ai vu
qui m'ont bouleversé dans le public et
encore voilà encore récemment
aujourd'hui enfin ça m'arrive toujours
quoi donc il y a aucune guerre moi je
suis pour la coexistence de toilettes de
tous les théâtres mais c'est sûr que il
y en a un dont la mission est d'arriver
à avoir des gens dans la salle ça c'est
le théâtre privé parce que s'il y a
c'est à dire que voilà
coexiste
et c'est le cas j'ai l'impression et moi
en tout cas il y a des acteurs qui font
le pont entre les deux et qui jouent
dans mes spectacles et qui joue dans le
tête pic mais c'est sûr que je vois mal
un instant public dire eh si on invitait
Alexis Michalik à monter un truc dans la
cour d'honneur mais si vous appelez ça
vous ferait plaisir quand même ça fait
toujours plaisir bien sûr je posais une
question sur la politique j'ai vu que
vous aviez signé une tribune dans
l'entre-deux tour de la présidentielle
ah oui c'est vrai j'ai fait ça moi
c'était quoi la tribu c'était une
tribune pour vous le savez mieux que moi
quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
quand vous avez références oui oui bah
oui bien sûr pour pas pour un appel à
papoter Marine Le Pen exactement quand
même Front national enfin j'ai pas
oublié ce que c'est quoi moi j'ai
demandé aux années 80 Jean-Marie Le Pen
il va fenest enfin bon bref les
citations sur
le détail de l'histoire les chambres à
gaz puis même enfin bon
vous voulez pas vous mouiller oui je
pourrais si jamais je trouvais quelqu'un
un homme ou une femme politique qui
m'inspire suffisamment
à la fois
un artiste parce qu'il va dire réussir à
faire bouger des lignes je me demande ça
m'épuise le débat
sur sur les réseaux sociaux et le
déferlement de
prise de parole politique mais de tout
bord et le ça me ça me fatigue d'avance
quoi moi j'aime bien
si je suis l'actu énormément mais mais
en revanche dès que dès qu'on va
annoncer quelque chose prendre prendre
une position derrière c'est juste
tellement de travail de se prendre les
commentaires de tous les mécontents et
tous les fâchés quel que soit ce qu'on
annonce que le jeu de la reine politique
me fait pas plus plutôt que vous voulez
pas vous mettre dedans quoi non enfin je
veux dire je sais ce que je pense et
j'ai des convictions et j'ai une pensée
et voilà moi je suis quelqu'un qui est
plutôt très à gauche idéologiquement en
tout cas j'ai un idéal de gauche et
le reste
j'ai toujours ouvert à toute discussion
mais mais je veux dire voilà
on y va tout le monde en fait j'ai
l'impression d'enfoncer les portes
ouvertes quoi je suis sûr que d'autres
gens le feront mieux que moi quoi
on arrive dans le vers parlons
d'enfoncer des portes ouvertes on arrive
au Théâtre des béliers est-ce que c'est
pas une transition parfaite mais vous
êtes au top
merci monsieur
est-ce que ça marche toujours
ce qu'on est toujours en train de
broadcast on a toujours en direct ce
qu'on est toujours en direct il est
23h25 merci beaucoup monsieur bonne
soirée
ouais c'est ma meilleure amie elle était
assistante d'ailleurs sur Edmond
d'accord mais avant on était déjà potes
avant ça et donc elle est elle-même
actrice et autrice et elle a écrit
plusieurs pièces il y a deux ans elle
avait écrit la 3 ans avait écrit la main
de Leila
des comédiens du spectacle et là c'est
sa dernière pièce qui s'appelle Les
Poupées personne et qui se jouent au
Théâtre
des béliers
ou bonjour bonjour ou vous avez une
pièce où j'ai une pièce depuis quelques
années qui s'appelle le porteur
d'histoire alors c'est là donc c'est
fermé parce que les gens sont déjà
sortis c'est normal donc là il y a le
porteur d'histoire qui se joue à 19h
depuis longtemps et les poupées persanes
voilà qui se joue juste après et 66
jours avec le Théo est-ce que le Beach
seul en scène c'est un théâtre qui
s'appelait le sudène avant qui était
tenu par Raymond Aquaviva et qui a été
racheté par Arthur Jugnot David Roussel
Bruno et Fred Thibault qui avait déjà
les béliers Avignon et donc ils l'ont
renommé les béliers parisiens
donc il y a deux théâtres des béliers il
y a le théâtre des béliers à Avignon et
le théâtre des béliers à Paris un jour
au passage obligatoire Avignon
moi j'y vais tous les ans ouais au moins
pour aller voir quelques spectacles et
j'y ai même j'aime tellement Avignon que
j'y ai acheté un appartement d'accord
voilà ça fait j'ai fait mon premier
Avignon en 2005
voilà et après j'en ai fait je crois que
j'ai fait 15 Avignon après ça donc voilà
chaque année et puis et jusqu'au jour où
je me suis dit bon allez j'ai gagné ma
vie je vais m'acheter un appart comme ça
je vais arrêter de m'embêter chaque
année à louer un truc hors de prix où je
me retrouve dans une sudette au sixième
étage sous les toits et donc maintenant
j'ai un petit appart au centre et le le
but c'était qu'il soit pile poil entre
les béliers et la place des Corps-Saints
et là où tout le monde boit du coup donc
et on parle en boire des coups la
transition on était dans la nuit noire
c'est ça et on arrive maintenant au
village au village qui est l'un des
l'un des endroits où les comédiens
boivent des coups après le spectacle
bonsoir ce que vous les voyez alors là
je vois un de mes comédiens Michael ça
va ça fait longtemps
tu jouais ce soir bon ça va alors
bonjour ils sont installés à l'intérieur
mais ils sont là ils sont dehors on va
aller voir ça ça s'est bien passé
l'histoire à 19h et là c'est la pièce
bonsoir c'est les poupées personnes qui
sont qui sont ici voilà ça va ça va
l'équipe
bonjour Thibault enchanté
de toujours
on l'a vu tout à l'heure sur la scène
des producteurs en train de saluer et
puis là en fait on le retrouve voilà et
puis là on le retrouve en train de boire
des coups sur les producteurs et après
metteur en scène c'est ça des poupées
personnelles
sur les producteurs c'est-à-dire le
mardi ok comme ça je peux venir les voir
et quand il y a une émission
quand vous êtes là on se met à côté de
vous est-ce qu'on peut s'installer
est-ce qu'on va réussir
en bas du coup est-ce qu'on peut
demander à une ou deux personnes de
partir Kamel
voilà donc il est comédiens sur les
poupées personnes bonjour
kamelisker Sylvain mousso Ariane Morier
à disque à bout les gens que je ne
connais pas dans ma série et on va
apprendre d'autres amis voilà alors on
va se trouver
dans pas longtemps là alors
on a vu la fin de la fin de la fin des
prods
on a commencé à 22h donc on est arrivé
cinq dernières minutes
10 5 10 dernières minutes on vous a
entendu faire des faire c'est toi tirer
au pistolet tout ça c'est une bonne
soirée ou pas est-ce qu'on sent la salle
est-ce qu'on sent que des fois c'est
mieux que d'autres
là ce soir sur j'étais en train de me
parler
timide et voilà on parlait très
justement et nous choisir quoi c'est
c'est de votre faute ou c'est la faute
du public
un ou deux fédérateur et puis d'un coup
ça va ça va ça va monter là sur les
producteur c'était c'était le c'était le
feu ce soir ça marche pas du tout vous
sortez de là vous êtes dépité ou il y a
une remise en question s'engage
je suis un peu metteur en scène oui on
va aller on va se lever on va aller un
peu plus loin et on va aller dire
bonjour à Ida aussi comme ça on va pas
avoir 14000 personnes
ouais ça va et toi bienvenue on vient
chez vous surtout voilà on va se mettre
ici
on va se mettre ici ça va être super on
va pouvoir discuter qu'est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup de malade
enchanté Régis voilà mes deux meilleurs
amis
et voilà on se connaît depuis maintenant
quelques années Régis et moi on a fait
notre premier spectacle ensemble qui
était le mariage de Figaro dont on
parlait tout à l'heure on a qu'on a
amené Avignon en 2005 mais avant ça je
l'ai découvert j'ai découvert au
conservatoire du 19e
qui jouait pantalon avec un avec un
masque et qu'il est rentré en faisant
du boulot
elle est venue à la base faire la
l'accueil pro d'un d'un de nos
spectacles Roméo et Juliette dont on
parlait tout à l'heure évidemment en
2008 7 9 9 peut-être un truc comme ça et
après on est parti faire le GR20 en
Corse c'est à dire le circuit que Régis
a fait deux ou trois fois de rando voilà
on est tous toi tu es de Bagneux et
d'origine iranienne
excessivement étonnamment avec
l'actualité c'est un spectacle que
j'avais envie de faire depuis super
super longtemps et ça mélange une toute
la partie de la révolution iranienne la
décennie où il y a eu la décision du
chat il arrivait de du régime islamique
avec une contrepartie en France où on
est un peu plus sur la comédie où on
suit une famille dans une station de ski
à montréat au passage à l'an 2000 et les
deux histoires vont se rejoindre alors
ça c'est l'histoire de votre famille ça
c'est l'histoire et oui
j'ai des trucs qui sont modifiés dans la
pièce mais ouais c'est bien sûr inspiré
de la vie de mes parents et donc vite
vos parents vous aussi je suis allé
chercher sur internet je vous ai écouté
vos parents ont quitté l'Iran à l'époque
en 82 oui ils ont quand même vécu la
révolution ils sont restés un petit peu
puis ils ont fui le régime des mots là
et ils ont vraiment eu un c'est
incroyable quoi ils ont traversé le
Kurdistan à d'autres chevals étaient
pris dans une campagne de neige soit il
est en Turquie puis en France donc c'est
c'est très très romanesque et en vrai
c'est la vie de plein plein d'Iraniens
de cette époque donc ce qui fait que
tous les soirs dans le théâtre on entend
des gens réagir comme si je racontais
leur histoire mais parce que c'est une
histoire qui est partagée
par beaucoup beaucoup d'Iraniens
avant de démarrer les répétitions pour
voir un peu comment c'était etc alors on
vous laisse rentrer on laisse venir
alors moi j'ai rien fait mal aux
personnes
en tout cas jusqu'à ce voyage jusqu'à
cette pièce
à l'époque de on a fait ce voyage en
2019 à l'époque j'avais on avait pas
encore commencé la répétition ni rien
et oui en fait même mes parents ils ont
pu y retourner beaucoup beaucoup plus
tard mais parce que ils étaient devenus
vieux ils sont plus très politisés
et moi j'ai pu y retourner deux trois
fois mais après c'est toujours périlleux
parce que on sait pas on nous a pas on
nous disant vous n'êtes pas en ce moment
et puis parfois c'est plus cool donc on
prend le risque d'y aller franchement
pas trop voilà là non mais même ça fait
deux trois ans qu'on nous dit de pas
venir par exemple justement votre vision
sur ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est
est-ce que c'est une joie ou une
tristesse là pour vous ce qui se passe
là-bas c'est un mélange des deux ça a
commencé par beaucoup de tristesse
maintenant il y a un peu de la joie dans
le sens où je commence à croire que
c'est possible qu'un changement est
possible alors qu'au début on comprend
le le ras-le-bol et la survie en fait
c'est vraiment de la survie de prendre
le risque de mourir pour eux
mais il y a presque un goût de
comment faire quel poids est-ce que
auront leur acte et en fait maintenant
vu l'ampleur que ça prend la résistance
que ça la la
c'est répandue dans plein de villes dans
toute milieu social confondu les jeunes
surtout je suis admirative de il y a
c'est des adolescentes parfois de
d'école qui protestent qui vire leur
prof qui qui tendent leur foulard donc
je suis très impressionné par tout ça et
c'est extrêmement important qu'on en
parle ici parce que tant qu'on en parle
ce mouvement existera et ne mourra pas
vous étiez à la manifestation dimanche
alors malheureusement j'étais sur scène
ok à 15h donc j'ai pas pu être à la
manifestation qui était à 15h aussi mais
j'ai ma famille était j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui m'ont envoyé des vidéos
un peu politique mais comment vous voyez
vous le débat en France sur la question
du voile parce que c'est ça la base
je comprends que pour nous qui sommes
libres
confonde ce problème c'est à dire que en
France on est libre de le porter ou non
donc c'est mais en fait c'est autre
chose là-bas le voile est obligatoire ce
qui veut dire qu'on n'a pas d'avis à
donner et donc là ce que veulent
d'ailleurs quand on entend les slogans
personne ne dit
à bas le hijab ou ils utilisent pas ce
mot ils disent ah bah le dictateur
liberté donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir
dire je veux avoir le choix de le porter
ou non c'est c'est il y a pas de
jugement pour l'instant sur est-ce que
c'est bien ou pas de le porter c'est
vraiment que chacun fasse qu'il veut
mais qu'on me la pose pas vous avez de
la famille là-bas est-ce que vous êtes
inquiète comment ça se passe c'est très
compliqué on est
les réseaux sont coupés l'Internet est
coupé c'est très rare les moments où la
communication passe donc oui bien sûr
bien sûr
les poupées personnes c'est quoi dites
nous les dates parce que je suis sûr que
ça va donner envie bien sûr
on est vraiment pas sur un si vous
faites où on fête
l'an 2000 à Avoriaz et plutôt assez
drôle bien le personnage ça fait du bien
ça joue tous les tous les soirs du mardi
au samedi à 21h le 4 des béliers
parisiens donc juste là on est passé
devant tout à l'heure
et le dimanche à 15h bon donc n'hésitez
pas vous pouvez y aller on a beaucoup
parlé avec Alexis vous parliez de lui
maintenant un petit peu
on est parti sur un plan de la rue c'est
parti
on peut s'asseoir
on peut déambuler un peu
on va peut-être avoir un peu de calme
encore plus de calme ça va être super
vous travaillez plus ensemble alors avec
Alexis plus beaucoup enfin vous avec les
producteurs
[Rires]
les commandes et puis quand
on joue pas avec lui on va à l'escalade
ou oui
en fait on passe nos vacances ensemble
quoi donc il y a pas de partout
alors moi j'ai fait un magnifique voyage
je sortais dans ce chagrin d'amour et
j'ai fait un magnifique voyage
comment chercher mon avis
à une télévision
[Musique]
et ensuite on a fait un petit road trip
dans les pays baltes voilà on est parti
à Tenerife moi j'ai détesté au bout de
cinq jours je suis rentré et je l'ai
laissé faire sa rando tout seul parce
que vraiment je supportais pas on était
en nous qui a été trop touriste et après
on est parti au Pays-Bas avec deux potes
c'était super on avait moi j'avais prévu
tout un road trip avec la plage tout ça
il y a plus pendant 8 jours c'était les
vacances de la déprime au fond du trou
on écrit ouais franchement ça ferait un
super film Le cœur des hommes en larmes
mais finalement non et puis sinon on va
surtout tous les étés on va dans le Sud
ou encore ce et là c'est plutôt ambiance
maison au bord de la sous la tonnelle
avec certains picoles puis d'autres non
mais j'adore faire la donc je fais
souvent des des grands repas des grandes
tablées moi j'adore manger donc voilà je
lis que du positif sur Alexis Quentin ce
qu'on peut avoir du négatif donnez-moi
ces défauts franchement
[Rires]
bah ouais c'est sûr que là c'est
vraiment le meilleur moment pour en
parler quoi vraiment vous adressez en
plus vous adressez en plus à vraiment à
des gens qui vont mieux
Régis depuis le plus longtemps puisque
ça fait
20 ans je pense pas loin des 20 ans
le négatif
tu peux balancer alors vous êtes
fachette
il est très politiquement correct donc
là depuis tout à l'heure vraiment il
cherche c'est bon évidemment qu'il a mis
le dossiers non il est on s'engueule au
ping-pong
parce que parce que il se match et parce
que moi je suis toujours sur la défense
et du coup ça le fait chier que je sais
pas pour ça
on s'engue parce que quand il joue au
ping-pong le mec ne lâche rien il est
hyper concentré c'est pas fun c'est pas
fun on est en train d'égal le rythme
cardiaque qui monte et vraiment il lâche
rien il est là ça sa tête elle bouge pas
il rit pas là il est sympa il est gentil
il sourit et tout ça quoi quand il joue
au ping-pong c'est fini il y a plus rien
il y a un mur donc je le déteste donc
est-ce que vous êtes déjà fâché pardon
dans le travail est-ce qu'on peut se
fâcher quand on travaille avec des
copains avec Régis on s'est engueulé une
fois ou deux mais ça se ça se résout
vite quand même quand il contient du
stress quoi
un spectacle secret on va dire
moi personnellement les 10 derniers
jours avant la première je me mets
angoissée je me mets pas sûr et
toi on veut du on veut du gras là on
veut
que moi qu'est-ce que et toi tu vas tu
vas tu vas tu vas tu vas une trace
sur les pincettes
non moi je peux jouer à des jeux genre
tout le temps genre vraiment des jeux de
société
cette carte etc tout le temps mais au
point que vraiment
pour gagner non mais tout le temps tout
le temps donc vraiment je pourrais
gagner
d'ailleurs
et ça peut donner envie de d'avoir envie
de le battre tu vois ça
j'ai préparé une petite fiche pour les
questions que je suis on a 2h
j'ai posé beaucoup de questions
franchement moi le car on a bien joué on
est sur la fin je pense que là sur le
Figaro live il y a plus grand monde de
série
qu'on pourrait regarder
on en a eu quand même je suis certain
qu'on a eu des questions moi je pense
que moi je pense qu'il peut poser des
questions meilleures que ça quoi il y a
vraiment de la bah c'est-à-dire que eux
ils me connaissent vraiment quoi
je sais pas je sais je sais pas je pense
que là c'est le moment où on a plus trop
d'idées pour la fin de la fin de
l'émission on a fait vraiment moi ça
fait une heure 45 que je parle non-stop
les gars
on a parlé de on a une question alors
qu'on dit est-ce que vous auriez aimé
par exemple je sais que les Jeux
Olympiques
vont avoir lieu forcément
pas du tout enfin c'est super pour lui
je suis hyper content j'adore Thomas
vraiment mais non non pas du tout parce
que déjà je pense pas que j'en suis
capable enfin c'est pas mon truc quoi et
puis j'ai pas du tout un truc de vouloir
toujours plus grand toujours plus pour
le coup c'est très grand ouais là c'est
très grand et puis et puis encore une
fois j'adore le sport mais c'est pas ça
c'est le fait de faire une commande ça
c'est une commande oui c'est ce qu'on
dit tout à l'heure moi j'ai la chance de
pas être obligé de faire une commande
donc ben c'est super je peux me
permettre de prendre les acteurs que je
veux même quand je monte une comédie
musicale je vais imposer un acteur qui
ne sait pas chanter pas danser Régis
quoi je vais poser je vais
pas arrêter pistonné c'est dégueulasse
non c'est pas vrai il a il a passé
l'audition comme tout le monde et il a
été vraiment choisi à l'unanimité des
équipes créatives quoi
j'ai jamais une commande dans ma vie et
vous ça nous arrive ça m'est arrivé
quelquefois
est-ce que c'était chouette
bonsoir mais toi-même des fois où le
projet t'embalète finalement tu l'as pas
fait bah oui c'est ça en fait c'est ça
en fait souvent quand on a la liberté ça
commence et je commence à travailler sur
un truc et puis au bout d'un moment je
me dis genre non j'ai plus envie et je
lâche quoi mais je passe à autre chose
et je fais plutôt un truc personnel en
fait c'est ça c'est que moi je comme
j'ai pas on parlait tout à l'heure de
des droits etc et de ben en fait moi
j'ai jamais vraiment couru après
l'argent et il se trouve que alors
le pognon quoi vraiment c'est son truc
on a encore cette question comment ça
marche de travailler entre amis est-ce
que vous l'appelez directement vous
dites Régis je sais je veux le mettre
dans ma pièce à chaque fois
là par exemple je lui pitcher un peu je
commençais un peu à lui parler de ma
prochaine pièce et je lui disais mais je
peux pas en parler mais mais je lui
disais je suis pas sûr qu'il y a un rôle
pour toi quoi parce que je sais on voit
la pièce machin je dis à mince là je
vois pas trop le placer une histoire
d'amour c'est pas et je dis bon écoute
des eaux mais il y a un rôle de mec et
je pense que je vais le jouer donc donc
je vais vraiment dit genre tu peux venir
mais ça va être pour faire de la régie
donc c'est pas très intéressant quoi tu
vois donc non c'est plus quand je peux
pas le mettre dedans je je m'excuse et
je lui dis bon bah ce sera le sera la
prochaine mais là il est toujours
heureux de le faire mais oui puis là il
sera sur les il est sur les producteurs
pendant bout de temps là donc ça va
super qu'est-ce que vous feriez là c'est
si on n'était pas ensemble et qu'on
devait pas couper quand ça va couper
vous sortez vous êtes devenus des pardon
des yeux de 40 ans attendez nous trois
parce qu'on est on a des ambitions
différentes
bah moi clairement ma soirée idéale là
ce serait joué au barbu donc
un jeu de cartes
un jeu de cartes on serait Quatre Barbus
direct d'accord
c'est dommage si j'avais su j'aurais
pris un jeu de cartes là
ça aurait fait une bonne séquence de
faim
vous savez que on est dans une caméra la
vie d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
évidemment sachant que moi
personnellement je ne bois pas d'alcool
ah oui c'est vrai je ne bois pas donc
vous avez vu j'ai jamais vu non pourquoi
pas envie peur c'est une question qu'on
m'a tellement posé dans ma vie est-ce
que vous fait culpabiliser de t'avoir un
peu ouais un peu parce que attention à
la marche
un peu parce que parce que c'est pas
dans l'habitude des gens quoi donc
personne ne me pose la personne me pose
la question quand on dit je fume pas on
dit pas ah bon pourquoi tu fumes pas bah
non je fume pas quoi mais en France tout
le monde boit donc c'est culturel quoi
il y a quelque chose où c'est anormal de
pas voir et donc la première question
qu'on peut c'est mais pourquoi comme
s'il y avait un trauma quoi mais non
j'ai vu jamais bu en fait à un moment à
14 ans j'ai dû boire une bière et je me
suis dit pourquoi ça ne sert à rien ma
vie sera meilleure si je ne bois pas
d'alcool vous avez choisi la séquence de
début tout à l'heure
vous avez deux metteurs en scène un
petit metteur en scène aussi mais plus
acteurs
je sais pas quel comment on va terminer
cette cette séquence on a commencé avec
les Molières de Monsieur non mais là ça
va il reste encore 10 minutes on y est
pas encore vous savez comment on termine
un plan en termine un plan on termine
avec Sylvain qui reste là et puis nous
on part vers l'horizon quoi d'accord ça
c'est naturel
en chantant
vous chantez un peu vous moi je chante
ouais complètement j'adore chanter c'est
pas vrai
je chante qu'est-ce que je chante les
amis ils ne connaissent par cœur
OK direct je suis
refaites
ou Eddy Mitchell Eddy Mitchell pas de
Boogie Willy My Way c'est ma chanson
en marchant et vous chanter
je vais pas chanter my way
on va être entre nous mais par contre je
suis sûr que Régis ou aida ont super
envie de chanter surtout aida moi ce qui
est bien c'est que quand je chante on
reconnaît tout de suite et tout de suite
la chanson
que c'est toi en tout cas on
a pas voilà
le métro ah le métro sévère dans le 5e
arrondissement
sur le métro
quel est le jingle de la RATP ah je sais
pas je connais la SNCF alors
d'autre part et la personne a reconnu et
là il y a eu il y a pas eu une note
dedans
la RATP je me souviens même plus mais en
tout cas elle a essayé de faire la SNCF
et ça fait ta ta ta
c'était tellement faux
passe partout
c'est vrai mais je suis pas directeur de
ça là ça change tout
je crois que c'est ici mais oui
complètement
vous avez passé une bonne soirée moi
j'ai passé une très bonne soirée ouais
vous aimez faire le
une sorte de bilan là comme ça qu'on
fait le tour qu'est-ce qu'il y a ouais
moi aussi
tu n'as pas de microide
un peu le bilan
vous revenez sur votre
ensemble dès que vous revenez voir les
pièces chaque soir
on est déjà passé devant tout à l'heure
mais
ouais c'est super non mais c'est une
belle histoire d'amitié quoi c'est à
dire c'est quand même assez rare de
pouvoir faire un métier où on bosse avec
ses potes et puis quand c'est fini bah
on continue la soirée avec eux on part
en vacances il y a quand même beaucoup
de gens qui qui seraient déjà
embrouillés depuis longtemps quoi donc
c'est
comme dans les vieux couples quoi donc
du coup voilà c'est génial de pouvoir se
dire que
que que
qu'on est dans nos vies les petits loups
craignait la critique ou pas la critique
vous sortez une pièce des spécialistes
viennent me voir les spécialistes du
Figaro notamment tout le monde créé
des moments vous dites non mais là je
vous disiez quelque chose et je voulais
tester
à 18 ans il faisait son premier
long-métrage caméra au point pendant le
mois d'août il avait monté un thriller à
18 ans après on se retrouve à faire la
première pièce il a 20 balais il monte
un spectacle avec avec 10 acteurs faut
déjà vraiment savoir ce que tu veux pour
savoir fédérer ça et puis d'une certaine
manière avoir
de l'ego
allez j'y vais je fonce et à l'époque il
y avait des moments où forcément on se
retrouvait à avoir des échéances où il y
avait des gens qui se retrouvaient
jugent de notre travail et à ces
moments-là je le voyais mal réagir parce
que il y avait un truc où il voulait
fédérer son équipe et que d'un coup on
puisse
critiquer notre jeunesse notre fraîcheur
il y avait un truc de je m'en fous je
veux pas écouter il y avait une
insolence comme ça et je trouve que ça
c'est
complètement assagi et apaisé avec le
c'est même plus que la sagit c'est un
truc de de
la bonne critique évidemment rend
heureux mais c'est un truc dont tu te
sens et les meubles qui sont rares en
plus
pas grave c'est comme ça moi j'avance je
fais mon truc
toi c'est intéressant
j'ai eu une
jusqu'à la fin vous pouvez dire
elle m'a répondu conasse mais bon
effectivement c'est pas grave enfin de
toute façon c'est plus facile de
critique quand on sait en fait quand
c'était
critiquer
tout va bien et là la salle est pleine
pour la table et ce sera le mot de la
fin j'ai une dernière question la
dernière
votre acteur préféré actuel celui avec
qui vous rêveriez de tourner celui que
vous voulez mettre dans une de vos
pièces ou dans un appartement
en fait je fonctionne
vous êtes bien vous êtes fan on est tous
un peu fan de quelqu'un moi je suis
vraiment fan des créateurs des metteurs
en scène des valisateurs des grands
messages d'audience je suis fan de je
suis fan de plein de gens Peter donc bon
ça va être compliqué
là vous faites un kiff c'est pas c'est
vraiment je peux vous dire plein
d'acteurs que j'adore
moi j'aime beaucoup j'aime j'adore du
jardin j'adore le louche j'adore il y en
a plein que j'adore du monde du
Pontel enfin il y en a il y en a
vraiment plein que j'aime beaucoup mais
mais le problème c'est que du soulier
j'adorerais du soulier mais le problème
c'est que moi quand je fais un spectacle
je fais pas un spectacle pour une star
c'est vrai que c'est pas seulement que
j'aime pas les stars c'est pas que
j'aime pas les stars c'est que quand
j'écris un truc je n'ai pas un rôle
prédominant et des rôles qui servent la
soupe il y a il y a que des rôles pour
une troupe et ça une star va pas venir
jouer dans un une pièce qui est pour une
troupe il va pas venir pousser un canapé
et jouer son rôle et repartir après et
lever une et lever un mur et jouer
pendant deux ans ou trois ans et être
content de venir jouer comme Benoît
koden qui va jouer 700 fois au Régis qui
va jouer 700 fois et alors au cinéma
c'est pas ça c'est autre chose mais
mais le truc c'est que dans ma façon de
d'imaginer
je vais jamais écrire pour quelqu'un et
c'est aussi ça quand je dis que bah ça
vient que de mon envie c'est que je
m'affranchis de ça en fait j'ai la
chance de pouvoir être toujours
l'histoire en premier et après si
l'histoire
il y a un personnage de l'histoire qui
va correspondre à un acteur que
j'adorerais évidemment que je vais lui
proposer et c'est pas sûr qu'il accepte
parce que ben ils ont des choses à faire
dans Edmond
disons que tous les acteurs qui sont
dans le film sont ceux qui ont accepté
on se le fait ce plan de fin allez bon
c'est parti on va marcher la caméra vous
la posez où il faut moi bah oui bah là
ici là en plein centre donc on
commencerait comme ça devant le théâtre
des béliers
puis on va devoir partir et aller boire
un verre quoi et surtout on chante
exactement
bonne soirée allez ciao les amis
je vais essayer de trouver un petit my
way
c'est vrai que c'est la chanson la plus
jouée en karaoké
c'est exactement ce qui va se passer
elle karaoké
alors c'est nul cette version ah trop
bien
[Musique]
tu sais